j'avais des personnes que je connaissais
pas qu'il y avait mon numéro de
téléphone qui m'a appelé tard le soir en
me disant ben voilà ça fait plus d'une
heure que je t'attends tu viens tu viens
pas
je l'aurais bonsoir vous êtes né le 11
janvier 1994 à Sarrebourg en Moselle en
même temps que votre frère jumeau
Tristan
vous dites mes parents se sont battus
pour nous avoir dans le test de
fécondité examen de surveillance du coup
on a toujours été une famille très unie
avant nous à mes parents et une fille
qui est décédée suite à une malformation
cardiaque donc ils se sont toujours
battus pour tout faire pour nous
aujourd'hui vous préférez passer du
temps avec votre mère plutôt qu'avec les
gens de votre âge
vous êtes fusionnel
à l'école c'est une élève sans problème
et vous avez une passion depuis l'âge de
8 ans le football j'ai commencé avec mes
frères et plus tard j'ai joué dans une
équipe féminine et en sélection nos
ailes Meurthe-et-Moselle à haut niveau à
quel poste j'ai fait tous les posts
football
dans le même hôtel là-bas les gens vous
connaissent bien ils vous ont vu grandir
et beaucoup d'entre eux sont devenus des
amis de la famille des amis très proches
donc on part en vacances chez eux on
passe de bons moments tous ensemble
là-bas vous faites très attention à pas
vous balader en maillot toujours en
short dès qu'on fait un foot ou un volet
toujours en short pour respecter
justement la religion musulmane donc les
femmes couvertes et c'est ce qu'on fait
même si on est des touristes je pense
que c'est important de respecter leur
quotidien
en 2005 vous entrez en 6e c'est aussi
l'année du boom des blogs sur Internet
vous ouvrez une page sur skyblog
vous en servez pour poster des photos de
vacances en Égypte et donner des
nouvelles de votre idole Cristiano
Ronaldo
ensuite cmsn alors le père il aime bien
MSN parce qu'avec la webcam on sait à
qui on parle on peut voir qui se cache
derrière l'écran contrairement à
Facebook
en 2008 comme tout le monde vous ouvrez
un compte facebook alors c'est la
plateforme idéale évidemment pour écrire
discuter envoyer des photos parler avec
vos amis en Égypte c'est pour ça que
j'ai créé mon compte à l'origine pour ne
pas avoir besoin de les appeler comme le
coup est très élevé
alors la seule mise en garde de vos
parents à ce moment-là c'est supprime
les photos provocantes quand tu en
reçois si j'avais des amis qui postaient
des photos de qui pouvaient être
provocantes je devais les supprimer tout
de suite comme ça il y a aucun problème
mais mon compte était normal sans amis
indésirable en 2011 vous avez 17 ans vos
parents vous offrent un smartphone et un
mercredi vous êtes en train de faire les
courses avec votre mère vous allez sur
les réseaux sociaux et vous découvrez
que votre mot de passe a changé
en rentrant vous essayez de vous
connecter avec l'ordinateur et vous
comprenez à ce moment là que vous avez
été piraté
tout de suite j'ai envoyé un message via
Facebook
pour leur signaler que mon compte avait
été piraté vous pensez que c'est
l'affaire de 24 heures en fait moi je
pensais que l'affaire allait être prise
en compte très rapidement mais il faudra
un an et demi
à partir de là vous retrouvez piégé
entre les mains du hacker désormais
votre vie numérique et visible partout
alors heureusement il y a rien de
compromettant au départ puisque comme on
l'a vu vous faites très attention les
photos etc à un moment vous découvrez
que le pirate collecte les numéros et
les opérateurs de vos contacts et qu'il
change leur mot de passe et c'est à
partir de là que l'arnaque a commencé
alors là vous allez porter plainte à la
gendarmerie et les gendarmes vous
demandent de n'en parler à personne il
vous disent il peut s'agir de ton petit
ami ou même de ton frère donc à partir
de là le problème c'est que toute cette
histoire elle reste entre vous et vos
parents et donc ça c'était la chose la
plus difficile à vivre parce que
recevoir des menaces des gens quand on
peut pas s'expliquer et se défendre je
pense que c'est la petite le pire des
sentiments
alors là le hacker commence à se servir
de votre compte à des fins
pornographiques il envoie des vidéos
porno à une amie de votre mère et vous
vous dites on n'avait pas le droit
d'expliquer à cette dame la réalité de
la situation quoi après avoir porté
plainte il nous était interdit
t'expliquer aux gens ce qui s'était
passé
alors résultat vous êtes victime de
crise d'angoisse et le médecin vous
arrête pendant un mois
en cours donc dans la voiture je me
sentais mal vomissez je pouvais plus je
m'arrêtais pas de pleurer c'était
vraiment horrible quoi je pouvais pas
passer la grille du lycée j'ai essayé à
maintes reprises mais c'était vraiment
impossible
parce que le regard des autres c'est
toujours là et on devient
soupçonné sur tout le monde surtout et
tout le monde quoi donc c'est invivable
ensuite le hacker se sert de votre
identité pour donner des rendez-vous à
des hommes
donc vous commencez à recevoir des
messages du genre t'es pas venu la
prochaine fois tu as intérêt à venir
quoi
j'avais des personnes que je connaissais
pas qu'il y avait mon numéro de
téléphone qui m'a appelé tard le soir en
me disant ben voilà ça fait plus d'une
heure que je t'attends tu viens tu viens
pas
ensuite il prend contact avec vos amis
égyptiens
et il envoie un message soit disant
signé par vous disant la prochaine fois
que je viens en vacances tu pourras
faire ce que tu veux tu pourras me
prendre par derrière
donc là c'était vraiment le point qu'il
fallait pas dépasser quoi en France
c'est pas la même ils ont pas les mêmes
pensées envers la sexualité ou quoi que
ce soit mon Egypte là c'était vraiment
le point le plus haut quoi il a tapé là
où il fallait c'était nos amis j'ai
réussi à avoir leur respect parce qu'ils
connaissent depuis que je suis toute
petite et là il a tout cassé en l'espace
de d'une phrase quoi une seconde
décide de rendre votre profil
confidentiel désormais il vous sera
impossible de savoir ce qui fait dans
votre dos en fait c'est ça donc il a
débloqué toutes mes informations
personnelles donc tout le monde voyait
d'où je venais quel âge j'avais mais il
m'était impossible de voir qu'il
ajoutait en ami donc au fur et à mesure
je ne pouvais plus contacter les
personnes pour leur expliquer que je
m'étais fait pirater mon compte quoi
alors là il y a des jeunes qui vous
disent bah disons sous tes airs de
sainte-nitouche tu t'éclates bien
derrière ton ordi quoi
c'est lui qui faisait les messages
évidemment c'est ça tout le monde
pensait que c'était moi donc leur
comportement est normal je le comprends
mais après je pouvais pas me défendre je
pouvais rien faire donc je devais ne
rien répondre alors un jour il y a une
footballeuse qui vous dit mais pour qui
tu te prends me traiter de [ __ ] je vais
te casser les genoux j'ai reçu ce
message et j'ai pas compris tout de
suite ce qui s'était passé parce que je
ne voyais pas ce que le hacker lui avait
envoyé et donc du coup il l'a traitée
elle me l'a expliqué par la suite qu'il
l'avait traité elle et sa famille et
donc elle attendait juste que j'ai 18
ans pour venir me casser les jambes pour
que je ne puisse plus jouer au foot plus
toucher un ballon de ma vie quoi
là vous devenez paranoïaque
c'est trop heureusement que j'avais
justement mes parents qui étaient avec
moi parce que sinon
en fait des cauchemars durant lesquels
vous rêvez que vous êtes violet vous
vous réveillez en arrachant les draps
pour vos parents c'est l'enfer c'est
l'enfer parce que j'étais avec du recul
je me suis rendu compte que j'étais
désagréable avec eux parce que c'était
les seules personnes sur qui je pouvais
m'énerver sur qui je pouvais rejeter
toute ma haine donc du coup c'est eux
qui ont pris je suis en train de devenir
folle quoi
des somnifères
et le compte de la perversion c'est
qu'en devant les lenteurs de la
gendarmerie vous ouvrez un nouveau
compte pour tout expliquer à vos
contacts et là le hacker entre en
contact avec vous
me dire ben tu vois même si c'est ouvert
un compte je suis encore là je peux
encore te bousiller
très inquiétant mais il discutera même
avec votre mère en utilisant votre
identité
quand je me connectais sur le facebook
de ma mère pour discuter avec lui pour
soutirer quelques informations et il me
disait mais t'inquiète pas samedi je
viendrai te voir quand tu sortiras en
boîte j'ai envie de faire la bise
film d'horreur j'ai une partie de mon
adolescente ou de mon adolescence où
j'ai rien fait parce que j'avais trop
peur de le croiser je savais pas que ça
pouvait être et du coup on fait rien on
reste chez soi finalement on retrouvera
l'adresse IP du pirate et le pirate donc
c'était qui ben c'était une personne que
je connais pas qui est habite la région
parisienne et donc j'ai aucun contact
avec lui donc c'était du pur hasard quoi
et quand je discutais avec lui il me
disait souvent si tu me trouves un bon
compte je te je te rende tiens un vrai
pervers
vous découvrez que vous êtes visé par
une dizaine de plaintes parce qu'avec
les numéros tout ça il avait acheté des
iPhone donc il y a des gens qui vous
disent voilà
faut rembourser c'était leur seule
solution pour qu'il puisse se faire
rembourser et donc du coup à 17 ans se
retrouvait avec des plantes je trouve
que c'est dur
surtout quand on a rien fait pour alors
aujourd'hui vous êtes sortis de la
dépression
le pirate court toujours
Roselyne
je trouve ce témoignage absolument
absolument bouleversant et
cet homme vous connaissez son identité
maintenant et vous allez le poursuivre
qu'est-ce qui vous dise à la gendarmerie
à la police c'est quand même incroyable
de dire que vous n'avez le droit de dire
de rien dire pourquoi je trouve
l'attitude des forces de l'ordre
absolument incroyable dans cette affaire
parce que dans un premier temps les
forces de l'autre de l'ordre pensait que
ça pouvait être quelqu'un qui était
proche de moi dont je ne pouvais pas
imaginer qu'il veuillent me faire du mal
justement même proche de vous il faut
poursuivre ces gens là ce sont des
pervers
c'est incroyable sur les réseaux sociaux
alors moi j'ai aussi sur les réseaux
sociaux j'ai été victime là récemment de
manœuvre absolument épouvantable ou des
faux mails ont circulé sur une prétendue
rémunération que je toucherai dans la
commission Jospin avec des des centaines
de milliers de mails qui ont circulé
sous le couvert de
vous êtes toujours sur Facebook
pour pouvoir expliquer aux gens que je
m'étais fait pirater mon compte facebook
et donc j'ai toujours
envie de plus du tout être sur facebook
j'ai sécurisé ce conte donc à chaque
fois que je me connecte je dois entrer
l'endroit d'où je me connecte et du coup
si quelqu'un d'autre se connecte sur mon
compte j'ai un mail qui m'est
directement envoyé sur ma messagerie
en tous les cas c'est de sécuriser leur
compte au moins voilà
vous êtes victime de Facebook vous serez
non j'ai pas de compte perso en fait sur
sur Facebook mais c'est vrai que c'est
c'est effrayant parce que c'est dingue
comme ça peut pourrir la vie de cette
jeune fille moi j'étais j'étais happée
par le témoignage ça me fait peur moi
tout ça c'est vraiment c'est pour ça que
je touche pas trop ça des surtout chic
me connais pas du tout donc je me dis je
saurais pas me défendre là-dessus et on
n'a pas attrapé le mec si on l'a attrapé
mais on a reçu une lettre comme quoi il
y aurait pas de fuite parce que on a on
aurait soit 10 ans identifié une
mauvaise personne alors que c'est un
rapport de Microsoft qui a identifié
cette personne et donc du coup il y aura
pas de fuite
mais justement c'est gratifiant pour lui
il sait que qui peut faire ça sans
détarité donc ça va être un cercle
vicieux et ça ira ce sera de pire en
pire
vous avez son nom là non je crois que
c'est Laurent Romejko
[Applaudissements]
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu